(audience cheering and clapping)
(gentle music)
♪ Go row the boat to safer grounds ♪
♪ But don't you know we're stronger now ♪
♪ My heart still beats,
my skin still feels ♪
♪ My lungs still breathe,
my mind still fears ♪
♪ But we're running out of time, time ♪
♪ Oh, all the echoes in my mind cry ♪
♪ There's blood on your lies ♪
♪ The sky's open wide ♪
♪ There is nowhere for you to hide ♪
♪ The hunter's moon is shining ♪
♪ I'm running with the wolves tonight ♪
♪ I'm running with the wolves ♪
♪ I'm running with the ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ I'm running with the wolves ♪
♪ I'm running with the ♪
♪ I'm running with the wolves tonight ♪
♪ I'm running with the wolves ♪
♪ I'm running with the ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)